russlands präsident wladimir putin
spielt derzeit eine wichtige rolle bei
den gesprächen über einen
waffenstillstand in libyen
schon im herbst 2009 10 war
medienwirksam der erste russland afrika
gipfel mit 40 staats und regierungschefs
und die patient 1000 teilnehmern aus 54
staaten abgehalten worden
heute in vechta kompakt russlands
rückkehr nach afrika
[Musik]
es war zu erwarten dass sich auch moskau
afrika zuwenden wird denn trotz aller
konflikte und krisen stufen china die
usa und die eu diesen kontinent schon
länger als wichtige und aufstrebende
region ein
auch indien und die türkei haben bereits
afrika formate eingerichtet russland
darf daher bei diesem wettbewerb nicht
fehlen muss kam dabei auf alte
beziehungen zurückgreifen viele jahre
hatte die damalige sowjetunion
afrikanische unabhängigkeitsbewegungen
unterstützt und sich auch militärisch an
konflikten beteiligt zum beispiel bei
der suezkrise 1956 mehr als 53.000
afrikaner studierten an sowjetischen
universitäten so zum beispiel der
derzeitige präsident mosambiks oder der
ehemalige präsident angola santos und
südafrikas jacob zuma allein 2018 waren
es über 17.000 heute können drei
übergeordnete russische interessen
identifiziert werden erstens bildung ist
strategischer allianzen in konkurrenz zu
anderen großmächten
zweitens erschließen von absatzmärkten
und zugang zu ressourcen sowie drittens
nutzung des energiemarkts für gesang
strategische zwecke konkrete vorhaben
die gespräche mit den typischen
kontrahenten in moskau und in berlin im
jänner 2020 haben gezeigt dass sich
russland neben syrien auch in nordafrika
als vermittler engagiert nachdem bisher
weder die usa noch die eu erfolgreich
waren könnte es für putin zumindest für
einen symbolischen erfolgreichen der
kreml möchte aber grundsätzlich
intensivere beziehungen mit
afrikanischen staaten
seine internationale bedeutung erhöhen
der afrika gipfel im herbst machte
deutlich dass russland neben der
strategischen präsenz neue absatzmärkte
und zugang zur wertvollen ressourcen
sucht das derzeitige handelsvolumen mit
afrikanischen staaten fehlt jedoch mit
20 milliarden us dollar bescheiden aus
im vergleich zu 204 milliarden chinas
über 330 milliarden der eu oder 60
milliarden der usa an bedeutung gewinnt
aber der rüstungsmarkt so dürften beim
gipfel mit 20 staaten abkommen getroffen
worden seien
mit einem geschätzten volumen von ca 13
milliarden us-dollar
russland war im letzten jahrzehnt zum
größten waffenexporteure nach afrika
aufgestiegenen hauptabnehmer sind
ägypten und algerien
das verkaufsvolumen betrug 2018 knapp
über 2 milliarden dollar circa ein
drittel aller russischen
rüstungsgeschäfte exportschlager waren
zuletzt helikopter panzer
luftabwehrsysteme und kampfflugzeuge und
2014 wurden nigerianische
spezialeinsatzkräfte in russland für den
kampf gegen boko haram ausgebildet
nigeria hat damals auch zwölf moderne
die 35 kampfhubschrauber bestellt in
etlichen staaten sind außerdem noch
viele alte rüstungsgüter aus
sowjetzeiten in verwendung die gewartet
werden müssen
großes interesse gilt der
zentralafrikanischen republik wo das
russische militär eine eigene präsenz
eingerichtet hat und sich in einer uno
mission - co beteiligt
besondere relevanz hat der energiesektor
denn einerseits können zum beispiel
teure russische atomreaktoren verkauft
werden
andererseits bietet die beteiligung an
lokalen firmen im öl- gas- und pipeline
bereich gute einnahmen und eine gewisse
kontrollmöglichkeit gegenüber europa so
ist etwa gazprom in algerien an der
gasförderung beteiligt gemeinsam mit
anderen wird eine pipeline von nigeria
über algerien
nach europa gebaut ägypten libyen und
algerien sowie teile westafrikas sind im
fokus russischer firmen
analysten gehen dabei von einem starken
zusammenhang zwischen russischen
beteiligungen im energiebereich und dem
engagement im sicherheitssektor aus eine
einschätzung mit dem verstärkten
auftreten in afrika versucht russland
seine position als geopolitische akteur
auszubauen
das klare eintreten für eine
nichteinmischung in innere
angelegenheiten und die unterstützung
ersatz in syrien dürfte bei manchen
afrikanischen machthabern aufmerksamkeit
erregt haben netzwerk aus alten zeiten
eine geschickte diplomatie studien und
wirtschaftsprogramme und nicht zuletzt
altes russisches militär gerät bilden
ankerpunkte für moskaus vorgehen
aus europäischer sicht könnten sich im
sicherheitsbereich etwa bei der
bekämpfung von terrorismus und der
stabilisierung libyens
kooperationsmöglichkeiten ergeben
energiepolitisch gilt es aber nicht
zusätzlich in russische abhängigkeit zu
geraten
militär strategisch ist zu bedenken dass
moskau bereits über eine starke basis in
syrien verfügt jede dauerhafte
einrichtung in nordafrika etwa in libyen
würde russlands einflussmöglichkeiten im
mittelmeerraum erhöhen
ein ausblick präsident putin möchte den
handel mit afrika in den nächsten fünf
jahren verdoppeln
selbst wenn das gelingt wäre moskauer
noch weit vom chinesischen oder
europäischen zahlen entfernt
allerdings hat man in den letzten jahren
gesehen dass entschlossenes auftreten in
krisensituationen eine überproportionale
bedeutung bewirken kann
russland könnte der gute karten haben
auch in afrikanischen staaten an
einfluss zu gewinnen
fraglich ist allerdings ob es dabei
nicht seine eigenen kapazitäten
überschätzt